In conventional medicine, all the focus is on sickness, all the focus is on disease and breast
cancer, all the focus is on the tumor. In any cancer, all the focus is on the tumor, but the
tumor's not the problem. The tumor is the symptom of the problem. This is Dr. Kevin Cutters.
Welcome to another episode of Cutters Clinic 5. I have a special guest I've interviewed before
Dr. Jen Simmons, who practices out on the east coast, well east coast, I guess pencil
lady isn't coast, but you practice in a way that's different than most medical professionals because
you originally practiced for years and years as a breast surgeon for breast cancer and then you
took a complete right turn and changed your whole practice into functional medicine for breast
cancer patients and that's what we're going to discuss today. What do you do and how could
my listeners benefit from your type of practice? But first before we get into that,
let's just have you kind of give a brief summary of your introduction again.
Absolutely. First of all, thank you for having me. I'm so happy to be here. I always love our
conversations. I love that you said that I made a right turn because I literally made a right turn.
So I come by being in the breast cancer space very naturally, very organically. I come from a breast
cancer family. My first cousin growing up was a woman named Linda Creed and Linda was a singer
songwriter in the 1970s in 1980s. She wrote all the music for the spinners in the stylistics. She wrote
54 hits in all and her most famous song was the greatest love of all. So she wrote that song in
1977 as the title track to the movie The Greatest during Muhammad Ali. But it really received its acclaim
in March of 1986 when Whitney Houston would release that song to the world. And at that time,
it would spend 14 weeks at the top of the charts. Only Linda would never know because she died of
menacetic breast cancer just one month after Whitney released the song. I was 16 years old when my hero died.
And her life and ultimately her death gave birth to my life's purpose. So I do the only thing I know
how to do. I become a doctor. I become a surgeon. I become a breast surgeon. I become the first
fellowship trained breast surgeon in Philadelphia. And I spend a really long time doing that
and thinking that I'm really serving a purpose and serving my purpose. And I'm about 15 years into
my career. And I'm running a very busy practice. I'm doing really novel things. I'm doing something
called ancha plastic surgery where I think I'm finding a silver lining for people and giving them the
opportunity to correct what they don't like about their breasts at the time of surgery. I'm also
running the cancer program for my hospital. I'm a wife and a mother and a stepmother and an
athlete and a philanthropist. So they have all these balls in the air. And I think that I can do it all
and have it all until I couldn't. And I went from being probably one of the most high functioning
people you've ever known to I couldn't walk across the room. I didn't have enough breath in my body
to walk across the room. And I spent three days having a very intensive workup. And at the end of
those three days, I'm sitting in the office of my friend and colleague in physician. And he tells me
that I need surgery and chemo radiation. And I'm going to be on lifelong medication. And despite the
fact that I say these things all day, every day to people without hesitation or reservation,
when the words are coming at me, I'm in Charlie Brown's classroom. I mean, all I hear is,
and my doctor told me as I had told hundreds of women before that, maybe even thousands,
if I don't accept this treatment, I'm going to die. And I know that it is the standard of care. I
mean, I am a physician who is running a cancer program. I know how this is treated. And yet something
in me, call it God, call it universe, call it whatever you want to call it, told me that there was another
way. So I go home, I leave. And I do what I tell everyone never to do. I go to Dr. Google.
Now this is 2016. And at that time, I think information was more available and more honest. I think
that now if you try to search for the truth, it's a very hard task. In that, Google is highly curated
and really all the search engines, all the readily available search engines, you can't really find the
answers that you're looking for. You find the answers that they want you to have. But at the time,
I was able to at least get a message that I needed to learn more about the meaning of food in your health.
So as a conventional medical doctor, I had 15 hours worth of training around nutrition in my first
year of medical school and then never again. And I had four years of medical school, five years of
residency, a year of fellowship. So I had a lot of training beyond my first year of medical school.
I know where in that training, did we ever discuss nutrition or nourishment? So I very reluctantly
enroll in the Institute for Integrative Nutrition. I am. It's a certificate program. And I must have
called them no less than 20 times to ensure that I was actually going to learn something because after
all I am a physician, and you know, what could I possibly do? So could I pause? Yeah, one second.
So here you have all this training in medicine. You are a accomplished surgeon,
leading a cancer center in a hospital. And then you end up with a serious diagnosis.
Yes. And that is the impetus that sparks like maybe there's another way.
Absolutely. And you start investigating this possible other way and you start to realize
what little you actually know about nutrition and diet and other avenues of healing.
But you are willing to be open minded. And maybe it's the spark of the seriousness of your
own condition that opens that up. It takes all, you know, somebody once said that, you know, you won't
learn anything new unless there's some sort of crisis or some sort of aha moment in your life.
I mean, we really don't learn through our successes. We learn through our failures. Exactly.
And the thing that I knew was that whatever I was doing wasn't working, right? Like I thought I was healthy
because I wasn't overweight. And I knew that my body was failing. So I knew that I had to change
something. I didn't know what the something was, right? So this was really my journey to figure out
what that something was. And I want to be clear, when I took this journey, this wasn't about helping my
patients kill from breast cancer. Like I, they weren't even part of the equation because I had no,
you don't know what you don't know, right? So I still, as I'm doing this, think I'm doing the right thing
for my breast cancer patients, it's just not me. And so one of the very first lectures
is a man named Mark Hyman walks on the stage. He introduces himself as a functional medicine physician.
Now remember, this is 2016. So I had never heard of him. And all I can think of in my snooty booty head
is I'm a physician for 20 years. There's no such thing as functional medicine. What is this
quack talking about? And then I remember that I'm sick. And I'm there for a reason. And so I check my
ego at the door and I tune in. And thank God I did because within three minutes of this man speaking,
my whole world makes sense. And I know exactly why I got sick. I got sick so that I could be in that
room on that day listening to him speak because what he's telling me makes my whole world make sense.
And I know that not only am I on the wrong path for my own illness by focusing on the illness,
but I'm also on the wrong path for my patients because in conventional medicine, all the focus is
on sickness, all the focus is on disease, and breast cancer, all the focus is on the tumor. In any
cancer, all the focus is on the tumor, but the tumor's not the problem. The tumor is the symptom of
the problem. And until you embrace that until you understand that, you cannot heal. And none of the
traditional, not shouldn't say traditional, let's say conventional, none of the conventional modalities
that we offer to people that we subject people to none of them have anything to do with healing.
In fact, most of them make people a lot sicker. And what made me not accept that for myself was
exactly why I went on this journey because when you hear about what happens to when you get chemotherapy,
you think like, I'm already sick and you want to make me sicker? Like it just doesn't make sense.
And I didn't think about it until I was feeling that pain. And so I spend the next three years
immersed in the study at functional medicine. And everything I learn pulls me more and more in that direction.
All the while, I'm continuing to operate on people. I'm continuing to act as a surgeon while I'm on my own
healing journey. But I'm not that typical surgeon. So I'm trying to talk to them about their diet and
are they exercising and how's their sleep? And what is your message? What is your breast cancer
diagnosis trying to tell you? And the vast majority of people looked at me like, I had 10 heads,
right? Because they're not accustomed to thinking this way. And they don't really, most people,
unfortunately, most people, they just want the pill or the knife or the drug or the procedure.
You know, they don't want to take control. They don't want to engage. They don't want to own it.
And that's fine. But once I finished. Well, right? So, of course.
So just like you've been indoctrinated through school, I mean, the pharmaceutical industry is doing
we have to give them credit. A wonderful job with propaganda. And me, isn't it?
Yes. Yes. So I realized at the end of that journey, you know, I healed myself.
Thank you know, by the grace of God, I healed myself. I learned what my body likes and what my
body doesn't like. I walk a very tight line because I want to be well because I don't want to be sick.
And there's no cake or drink or night out or, you know, there's not none of those things are as
important to me as my health. And once I run that bell, especially once I did that for me,
I knew I couldn't offer less to my patients. And so I left surgery mostly because the hospital
was paying me to operate, right? They weren't paying me to counsel people. They weren't paying me to
talk to them for hours about how they can recapture their health. They were paying me to be
in the operating room. And that wasn't where I was making the biggest impact, right? Because
unless you get to the root cause, unless you help people to correct their course, all I was doing in
the operating room was delaying the next manifestation, right? I was either delaying recurrence or I was
delaying the next disease that is going to happen, unless you deal with why the disease happened
in the first place. Well, Dr. medicine does not look at cause whatsoever. No. Sure. Now this is a
ginormous flip-flop for you. It is. Evidence. Evidence leaves the hospital, starts your old practice
and then decide what that practice is going to be focused on. I mean, most doctors that go into
they have years of decision and thought process and philosophy that got them to the point of how
they're going to run their practice. This happened in a relatively short period of time for you.
It did. When did you open up your old practice and how did you decide to focus on what you're doing?
Yeah. So I opened my practice real health MD in 2019. And you know, I think in the beginning,
when you train in functional medicine, you kind of become a jack of all trades. I mean, you learn
that you can help people with a lot of chronic issues. But breast cancer was always my calling.
It's always my space. And it remains my space. And I'm so grateful that God gave me this purpose.
Everything I have is from God. God gave me this purpose. And I'm so grateful for the opportunity
to be a trusted guide for women on a breast cancer journey. And the impact that I am able to make
as a functional oncologist as an integrative oncologist is so much greater than my work as a surgeon.
That was an amazing time and an amazing privilege. And I did that for 20 years.
But my work now, when I help a woman heal from breast cancer, I don't just help her.
I help her spouse, her partner, her children, her parents, her friends, her community.
Because once you get healthy, and once you know what it feels like to truly be well,
you can't keep that inside. That radiates from you. And that just grows. And so I
I am so humbled by the role that I have been able to play in people's lives and people's healing
and just allowing them the opportunity to live their best lives through the lens of a or through
the window of a tragedy. I mean, it's just it's the most amazing privilege. And I thank God every day
that he put me here for this. Well, let's get to the ditty gritty. Let's say we want to know what
you do for people. Say you get a call from somebody, a gallon, fill it out. He was just diagnosed with
breast cancer. Does it have the full specs yet? But they're already pushing them, as you know,
instantly into the chemotherapy, radiation, surgery, pathway. What would you do for them?
Yeah. So, you know, the first thing I tell people is to slow down and take a breath.
They the conventional medical model scares you and tells you that you have to act immediately.
They do that very intentionally. They don't want to give you a lot of time to think because they don't
want you to consider other options. They want to sign you off and get you through cancer care as
big business. And that is not to say that the providers don't care. They do. And that they're not
doing their jobs well. They are. But their jobs are to operate and to give chemotherapy and to give
radiation. And that's what they're trying to do when they're trying to do that really well. The problem
is that's not the that's not the solution for you. And with rare exception, the exceptions are
an inflammatory breast cancer where if someone has brain metastasis and it's like a space to
occupying issue where they're seizing or herniating or something along those lines or you're
in intractable pain from bone myths, those are emergencies and those need intervention right away.
But that is the absolute absolute minority. And the vast majority of people
have plenty of time to learn about the disease, to learn what it means, to learn what it is,
and man, to figure out what the best solution is for you. And what we all need to understand is
breast cancer and all cancers for that matter. Cancer is a normal response to an abnormal environment.
Something is telling those cells that they are unsafe, that they have to go into survival mode.
You know, we are all the same in that. We are all about survival. And that is what
procreation is about survival of of whatever organism person. That that's what procreation is about.
It's about survival. And with cancer, something is making those cells feel unsafe.
Now to be clear, like people with breast cancer don't have a bad breast. And those
breast cells are not a foreign invader. Your cancer is a part of you. It's the part of you that
doesn't feel safe. And certain organs are definitely more sensitive to environmental disturbances,
breast, the breast cells happen to be one of the more sensitive cells, thyroid cells also sensitive.
And so the more sensitive cells, the more cancers we're going to see in those organs. But
it has nothing to do with the breast necessarily, right? It's not the environment of the breast.
It's the entire environment that is undergone a shift. And so what I help people to do is identify
what was that shift? Is it trauma? Is it stress? Is it mold? Is it viruses?
You know, have you had a chronic illness? Are there food sensitivities? Are you not eating in
the right way for you? Are you not exercising enough, not moving enough? Being sedentary is very
dangerous. Are you moving too much over exercising causes a lot of inflammation? But with a chronic
disease, there is going to be a common denominator, maybe more than one. But something is driving
inflammation. Something is changing the chemistry. And cancer is just responding to that chemical shift.
So helping people understand the systemic issue underneath the cancer, which is just the tip of the
ice program, that person's health issue, is getting to some deeper causes for you. So you do some
different labs. I take it. I do. So I run both general labs because
the ranges that we as conventional medical doctors accept are huge. And that's because conventional
medical doctors don't really know how to optimize your health. And so they don't know optimal levels.
They only know, they only understand failure. But you know, if you have diabetes, you don't go from
being not diabetic one day to diabetic the next, right? There is an entire range that usually takes
about 10 years to become diabetic. And so in that time, all along the way are opportunities to
correct. So I order general labs. I look at them through a functional lens. So let's take your white
blood cell count, for instance. I think like the acceptable range on lab core requests would be
3500 to 10,000, let's say. But I know that someone who is walking around with a white blood cell count
of 3500 is immunocompromised, right? And cancer is a balance between your body, your exposures,
and your immune system. So if your immune system is exhausted because it's been working around the
clock because it's challenged somewhere else, like you have suggested issues or you're exercising
too much or you're being exposed to mold or parasites or pesticides, herbicides, fungicides,
glyphosate, whatever it is. If something's taking out your immune system, it can't do the surveillance
that it needs to do. And in our body, we are constantly reproducing ourselves. And we're going to make
mistakes, right? We are going to make reproduction mistakes. Those mistakes are actually cancer cells
and an intact immune system will be able to recognize those cancer cells in their infancy and destroy
them. But if you are immunocompromised because you have gluten sensitivity and you don't know it and
you're eating bread every day, that immune system is not going to be able to do its job somewhere else.
And so this is what's happening all day every day. So I look at a CVC, a complete blood count
to a completely different lens. And when I see a white blood cell count of 3.5 or 4.5, I know that
this person has an immune challenge. I have to figure out what that immune challenge is. Another example
is thyroid health. So there are lots of cities that have fluoride in the water. Most people are
still using fluoride toothpaste. Fluoride will replace iodine on in thyroid hormone. And so you
can have normal levels of thyroid hormone and have a lot of thyroid dysfunction because your iodine
has been replaced with fluoride. If you have thyroid dysfunction, you are three to four times
more likely to get breast cancer than if you don't. So lots of people are walking around with
hypothyroidism. They're not adequately treated or they're improperly treated and their labs are
normal because their physician doesn't know how to read it or doesn't know that they could be walking
around with thyroid hormone that has fluoride inside of iodine. And these people are then just going on
to the next manifestation. Unfortunately, I only get to see them once they've developed the disease.
So I definitely would have labs just like your primary would, but I look at them through a different lens.
And then I would have functional labs. I'm looking at gut health and I'm doing microbiome testing.
I'm looking at metabolic health and doing testing of your mitochondria to see if healthy
your mitochondria are. Since answer is mitochondrial dysfunction and mitochondria are the energy generating
units of the cells and we need to make sure that they are functioning properly. And there are lots of
things in our environment that will interfere with that. I'm looking at hormone balance. I'm looking at
what are your hormone levels? Not only how are you making them, but how are you clearing them? Do you
have enough hormone? Because the vast majority of the breast cancers that we see are the postmenopausal
population. So we're not talking about hormone overload causing cancer, but instead it's the withdrawal
of the hormones that have the greatest negative effect. And that's when we are developing breast cancers.
And then I'm looking at your DNA. I'm doing gene testing to see how we can best nurture your nature
because we all have a gene code. And this doesn't mean that we are destined to be something because
your genotype isn't always your phenotype. So what your genes say isn't always how you look. But
there are ways to support your genes to get you optimal health. And so I'm looking at all of these
things. And I'm creating a life plan for people so that they can have the health that they deserve to
have. And most of them, most of my patients, have better health after their breast cancer diagnosis
and after working with me. Then they ever had their whole lives before. And for the first time,
they know what it feels like to be healthy. Well, it sounds like you're taking a, you know, a big
picture approach in the world where the practice of medicine has become more and more too,
did too. Oh, you have a UTI go to the urinary tract specialist. We have stomachache. We
get you to do a gastrointel. And you can't really treat the body that way because our systems aren't
separated from one another. They are, you know, continually intact in that they all have to work
together. So, you know, you know, that I love your approach. And that's why we're talking
and why I think this is the only way to really help a person is to look at the whole person.
How can people get in contact with you?
So, my website is Real Health MD. And then you can follow me on social media. I'm Dr.
Jen Simmons and my Jen has two ends. I have a Facebook group that people are welcome to join
called Keeping Abressed with Dr. Jen. And my podcast logged last month, also called Keeping Abressed
with Dr. Jen. And you can get that anywhere that you get your podcasts. And super exciting that
my book is coming out in a couple of weeks called The Smart Persons Guide to Breast Cancer. And so
that will be available to everyone. Well, it's so exciting to see what you're doing. I am just
anxiously waiting for your book. And can't wait to read that. And I just applaud everything
that you're doing. We're going to try to push people to your information. I just think that the
more educated a person is, the more wisdom you have at your disposal to make better decisions.
That is for sure true when you know better, you do better.
Yes. Thank you, Dr. Jen. I appreciate you being on. And we'll have you on. Again, I hope.
My pleasure. So happy to be here.
All right. Bye-bye.